people take something from the set and
over the years of doing this show I've
talked to many people when you know
friends is wrapping up or Seinfeld or
something and they all take some piece
of the set or something from the show
I imagine you and your cast mates are
doing that yeah I did I think some
people got a slightly better deal than I
did
I know Liam who plays Davos Seaworth he
took he got like a dothraki Erik like
proper sword and a load of other things
Connell Ethel who played Varys took his
rings with him he gets all those cool
ring you got all the chuckle rings I on
my very last day on set suddenly
realised I hadn't taken anything with me
and it wasn't gonna be possible to get
the wheelchair through customs so I so
to be fair it's not a great wheelchair
it's like made of bamboo you know so I
literally ran through the set I was on
and grabbed anything I could so I took
with me from the Game of Thrones set
which has incredible things on it
I took a wooden spoon a straw bowl and a
wooden tub of as far as I can tell is
Vaseline so everyone else has taken some
pretty cool things and I've got kitchen
utensils and lip balm
you took stuff that like you could just
take from any like Polynesian restaurant
you know look at this wooden ball remind
you of anything
no how about the ones